the darkest object in our night sky
is a black hole its gravitational pull
is so
immense that not even light can escape
it
as its mass increases it can trap more
and more
black holes can even swallow entire
stars
some astronomers describe them as the
darkest secrets of the universe
thanks to three scientists we all better
understand what they
are if there is a certain amount of of
of matter which is imploding
contracting then it's inevitable
that they will form what is a black hole
professor roger penrose from britain
reinhard genzel from germany and
american andrea guezz
are all credited with discovering
elements that make up black holes
and are the winners of this year's nobel
prize in physics
it was in 1965 that penrose first proved
what black holes are and how they form
describing them in detail and stating
that at their
center time and space ceased to exist
penrose went on to work with the late
stephen hawking who revolutionized our
understanding of time and space
professor pinrose from oxford university
was awarded half of the nobel prize
gonzalenges shared the other half for
discovering that an invisible and
extremely heavy object
governs the orbits of stars at the
center of our galaxy
together their work described
characteristics of black holes and super
black holes
most many times larger than the mass of
our sun
it wasn't until april last year that the
first image of a black hole was captured
blurry but visible this idea that
space which we we experience as humans
as separate from time
become commingled it's it's both
intriguing and fascinating and i have to
say these are the things that kept me up
at night when i was a kid
andrea guez achieved another milestone
by becoming only the fourth woman to win
a nobel physics prize
it's always been very important to
encourage
young women into the sciences
so to me it means an opportunity and a
responsibility
to encouraging the next generation of
scientists who are passionate about this
this kind of work into the field
following legends such as albert
einstein and stephen hawking
the winning trio of scientists keep
paving the way to better understand
former mysteries leah harding al jazeera